I ended up working at a furniture store
in Canada my sales manager had a half
brother that would come in and I thought
this guy was a drug dealer brand new
Escalade brand new Corvette I was like
what's this guy do turns out he was an
online marketer the guy's making like
750 000 a month doing bulk commercial
email marketing with affiliate products
so in two hours he could reach 8 million
people's inboxes and when we were
hanging out he wanted to go party I was
like I can't go party with you I have a
job So eventually that annoyed him
enough that he was like quit your job
come work for me I needed you to come
party with me we went to Vegas one time
stayed there for 45 days straight he
spent two million dollars I started
going from making 10 to 15 000 a month
to making a hundred which was
mind-boggling to me my dad would always
say it sounds too good to be true it
probably is and I've learned don't ever
believe that there are so many things
that sound too good to be true that are
[__] true